hey out there welcome into another
exciting i hope it's going to be the
best edition yet of market takes i am
dion rabone reporter at the wall street
journal i want to thank all of you all
out there for tuning in to our very
special jobs report edition of market
takes we are just going to be unpacking
the jobs report this morning talking
about what we saw what we found and why
it matters and i'm going to be giving
you some inside information about you
know what's what's really moving in that
report and what are some of the little
details uh that i think are important to
pay attention to and to lock in for
we're also going to talk about what the
market's seeing and taken away from this
and how this could move stocks bonds
commodities uh bitcoin crypto etc going
forward so we're gonna jump into into
all of that but wanted to thank you
again for being with us here on this
live stream uh we we usually do it on
mondays but every now and then we get a
big market-moving economic piece of data
that you know inspires us to come on
here and and let me talk a little bit
straight to you so we're doing that this
morning with the june non-farm payrolls
report and we're going to dive into that
so
what did the what did the jobs report
this morning tell us well it told us
that hiring is still strong we got 372
000 jobs added in june uh the pace is
still strong way above expectations
though slowing a little bit from the may
pace but the big picture you know we
we've known that this economy was adding
jobs we've known that the labor market
was strong and tight
but what did we really learn about
inflation and what do we learn about the
possibility of recession so we are going
to dive into all that so look
how did what we learned in this job
report compared to what we knew before
what does this jobs report tell us about
the overall pace of inflation and
particularly wage inflation on the labor
market side that's something fed chair
jerome powell has really pointed to as
being a potential a potential problem
area for the economy as you know one of
those wage price rate wage price spirals
that we could see um and the big
question is how are companies going to
respond if we just keep taking higher
that's a bigger piece out of company
profits that means stock prices could go
down that could be another thing that
contributes to the recession and you
know the other thing is a strong report
on the jobs front could be negative for
markets and i'm going to talk about why
that could be and what we're seeing but
the big question is the r word recession
what is this jobs report that we got
today tell us about the potential for a
second quarter recession as we said in
the title and the headline of this
report this is probably one of the
biggest if not the biggest pieces of
data that we've gotten about the second
quarter so far if you remember the first
quarter we had negative gdp now
traditionally when there's two quarters
back to back of negative gdp that means
a recession well we've already got one
in the books and the atlanta fed if you
watch their gdp now uh report is
predicting negative two percent growth
in the second quarter that would be
back-to-back quarters of negative
economic growth which would likely mean
that we are in a recession right in the
second quarter uh that that's already
happened but what does this jobs report
tell us about that likelihood um and you
know what were some of the potential
negatives even though we did see that
strong number overall on the headlines
so we'll get into all of that
everything about inflation recession and
the labor market but first let's check
in and take a look wsj.com at how the
market reacted now those futures prices
were lower immediately after the report
came out we did see the market pick back
up especially the dow uh and the s p a
little bit um even going positive for a
brief second right as the market opened
we've seen that reverse and now stock
markets basically the stock market
across the board is negative the dow is
down about point four percent s p 500
down about point six five percent the
nasdaq is off about point nine percent
down almost one percent still not at
those lows that we saw before the market
actually opened but the stock market's
saying uh we're not exactly excited
about this look
i think more important than the stock
market is what we're seeing right now in
the bond market we have seen a yield
curve inversion for the second time this
year that's where the two-year yield has
a higher is higher than the 10-year
yield essentially if you own a two-year
bond if you borrow money or if the
government borrows money from you and is
gonna pay it back in two years they're
paying you more than they would if
they're gonna pay it back in 10 years if
you just think about that that doesn't
make sense because people are more
likely to pay you back in two years you
also want to get your money back in two
years more than you want to get it back
in 10 years you'd want to take less
money for that you'd think but right now
investors are saying
down the road is not looking so great we
want to get that money now rather than
in the future
and and that's why you've got
two-year yields above 10-year yields
that is a long-term recession indicator
we saw the yield curve invert a couple
of months ago it is now inverted again
uh we i've got a whole video out about
some of these recession indicators can
be coming out a little later today so if
you're on my channel page on youtube
make sure you check that out we talk
about four big recession indicators that
markets tell us and that's gonna be
coming out on my youtube page a little
bit later today
the other big thing that's been kind of
portending a recession has been some of
these commodity prices we have seen big
declines in the price of oil oil up
right now on the back of this about
point six percent but we are down well
below that 120 dollars a barrel level
where we were
just a couple weeks ago now at about 103
103 a barrel that is a significant step
down natural gas well below where it was
so
those things are good for your bills
hopefully that means the price of gas is
going to come down hopefully it means
some of those utility bills are gonna
come down but
those prices are coming down because
investors are predicting a weaker and
softer economy going forward that's the
big picture there we've seen that with
oil we've seen it with copper prices
those are down as well so make sure
you're keeping an eye on those commodity
markets because they tell us a lot about
what investors are thinking so look
jumping back into the jobs report and
the information that we got today
372 thousand jobs added in june that is
a a well above expectations number
economists had been predicting about 260
000 uh we got 276 000 excuse me uh
according to factset and we got 372 000
so almost 100 000 more jobs added than
expected uh now that is down from the
pace that we saw in may of 390 000 but
again we are still well above
expectations and still well above the
pace needed to add jobs to just keep up
with the population
what could be some of the biggest
takeaways from this report we're going
to get into all that but the number one
takeaway that i have when you look
through the numbers and you see this
strong report
the negative takeaway is that it means
the fed probably needs to do more it
likely means a 75 basis point rate hike
is locked in for this month at their
meeting
that's three times the rate that they
normally raise rates at they did it in
june it's likely they're going to do it
again in july atlanta fed president
rafael bostic was in a meeting this
morning discussing what they'll likely
do he says you know what the case is
there for us to raise rates at 75 basis
points this month he thinks they're
gonna they're locked in for this pace
he's not a voter so he doesn't actually
get to vote this year but generally
speaking he's in line with the consensus
of the federal reserve and of fed chair
jerome powell the most important member
of the federal reserve so we can expect
that to be locked in and markets are
telling us that they expect 75 basis
points
rate hike this month at the fed's
meeting
what that means for you if you've got a
credit card those credit card rates are
going up if you've got a personal loan
those rates are going up home equity
line of credit uh things like that all
those variable rates that you have
variable interest rates those are all
going to go up and they're going to go
up by quite a bit so be sure you're
checking your statement if you're only
making those minimum monthly payments
you might want to think about paying a
little bit more um
listen what we learned about inflation
that's been the big key right because
we've known the job market is strong but
what did we learn about inflation from
this jobs report well average hourly
earnings up by 5.1 percent uh they
revised may higher to 5.3 percent but it
looks like we're starting to flatten out
on that average hourly earnings number
now that's a good thing and it's a bad
thing it's a good thing because
it means that those wage increases are
starting to moderate fed chair jerome
powell was very worried that we might
have a wage price spiral which is where
wages just keep rising and rising rising
getting out of control and that just
keeps inflation elevated it doesn't look
like that's the case here five point one
percent after five point three percent
and if you remember in april we were at
five point five percent we were at five
point six percent in march so wage gains
are slowing down the pace of increases
is slowing down and that's a good thing
for overall inflation
um for the lowest wage workers average
hourly earnings remained high that means
the lowest wage workers people who are
being paid the least are seeing the
biggest wage gains uh the atlanta fed
tracks this it's going about 6.5 percent
compared to that 5.1 percent rate for
workers overall so
low wage workers are seeing the biggest
increases from this
those folks who have been at the lowest
end of the economic totem pole getting
the biggest boost that's a good thing
why this is a bad thing well wages
aren't keeping up with inflation if you
remember uh last month we got the cpi
report on inflation for may that showed
that inflation was rising at 8.6 percent
so inflation was 8.6 percent in may and
in june we saw the pace of wage growth
is sliding and coming down now it's at
5.1 percent moving further away from the
pace of overall inflation
that means that workers wage increases
their pay gains are not keeping up with
inflation that is a bad thing
um this could also be the first preview
of what inflation and that cpi report
will show us for july if you remember we
got the jolts report job openings and
labor turnover survey that just means
how many job openings are there how many
employers got those how many employees
are are now on the rolls how many
workers got those jobs that were
available joel's repo jolt's report
showed
job openings fell in may but still over
11 million uh openings the number of
people looking for workers outnumbered
the number of unemployed workers almost
two to one 11.25 million job openings to
5.5 million unemployed workers and the
caveat to this very strong report that
we got today is labor force
participation
declined that's probably what kept the
unemployment rate about where it was at
3.6
and we are still well below the number
before the pandemic labor force
participation 62.2 percent was 63.3 63.4
percent in february of 2020 there are
still
524 000 less people employed right now
in june i'm sorry at least in june of
2022 than there were in february of
2020. we've had a population growth
since then we've had a lot more folks
turning 16 turning 18 entering the labor
force and there are half a million fewer
people employed now than there were two
and a half years ago before the pandemic
that's something to keep in mind when
you're seeing these numbers don't forget
that
so
let's look at the likelihood for
recession if we are in a recession this
is an unusual recession and that's
something to keep in mind hiring kept
pace with the gross of pop with the
growth of population yes absolutely
but
those wages are not keeping pace with
overall inflation and we are not seeing
any signs that inflation is going away
anytime soon looks like it's moderating
like we said that oil price has been
going down if you've noticed the price
of the pump has been going down those
that's been a big massive contributor to
the pace of inflation
but again
it's not looking like we are seeing
wages keep up with overall price gains
and that could be the thing that really
tips the country into recession now just
looking at it from a jobs perspective a
leading economic indicator is the
average weekly hours worked by
manufacturing workers that stayed high
stayed at 40.5 hours that's little
change from may that's one of the lei
one of the secret indicators uh that
economists really look to as a leading
indicator of recession that stayed right
where it was didn't move very much from
may suggesting that employment growth is
not slowing down we're not starting to
see significant layoffs um
ours matter and the reason that why
economists watch the average hour list
average hours worked is because it
really before employers start laying
people off they start cutting hours when
you start to see hours getting cut
that's a sign that ah we may be going
into a time where we're seeing more
layoffs more job cuts
now that challenger job cut report from
challenger gray and christmas it's a
little watched report but one that i've
been watching lately because you're
hearing all these talks about layoffs
and tech you're in all these talks about
layoffs in the financial industry etc
etc well if you look at the straight
numbers layoffs did increase in june but
only up to about 35 32.5 000 last month
that's 50 percent above where they were
in may but that's still well below and i
mean 12 000 below the trend of layoffs
from 2015 to 2020 right before the
pandemic so really till the end of june
or to the end of 2019. that five-year
period the economy was good the economy
was strong the stock market went up we
were not anywhere near a recession
and job cuts averaged 44 000. we're just
now getting back up to 32 and a half
thousand in june still well below the
pace that we saw from those five years
even before the pandemic so not counting
those huge losses
again
so job cuts are starting to pick up we
did see 32 000 up from about 20 000 the
month before
but that's still well below the pace
that we saw even when the economy was
good chugging along doing well
essentially for the country overall look
the big picture is if we are in a
recession and the odds have grown
immensely as you look at that atlanta
fed gdp now if you look at retail sales
if you look at some of these other
reports that we are in a recession right
now in in the second quarter and as we
move into this third quarter in the u.s
odds of a recession have increased
pretty significantly but
if we are in a recession it is a very
strange and unusual recession one that
may include continued job growth that
may include an unemployment rate at
around three and a half percent uh and
may include some of the things that we
really haven't seen before in the u.s
economy so look takeaways as we wrap it
up here on market takes uh the jobs
report showed strong hiring again it was
a lot of people were worried that oh we
could turn around we could see the labor
market turn over didn't happen wage is
strong job growth strong continued
hiring
but that's worrisome because it means
the fed still has a lot of work to do
and we could see a lot more rate hikes
in front of us
no wage price sprite no wage price
spiral try saying that three times fast
but again wages not keeping up with
inflation and
this could happen we are we have just
seen we've gone through a period where
things are not the way they were before
the labor market doesn't work the way it
is before and that's going to continue
so if we do see a recession if we are in
recession even with a 3.6 unemployment
rate don't be that surprised that's all
i'm saying look thank you all for tuning
in to market takes i am deon robon
reporter with the wall street journal we
are going to be doing this again next
week so please check in and stay with us
uh we're going to keep doing this this
live stream and we hope to see you there
with us i'm me signing off right now but
thanks everybody for tuning in i hope to
see you